this is a new report from cnr.com shock
poll majority of firsttime Iowa caucus
goers support V ramaswami Trump is in
third place among this group with 29%
surprisingly I I believe it's Nikki
Haley what who has second place right
well hers her numbers come from
firsttime GOP caucus goers and it's
because she has a lot of Democrats
caucusing exactly and so these are
people that are not actually going to be
voting for Republican in in in the in
November this is the this is the crazy
thing I saw I think Mark cubin tweeted
this calling for crossover voters
Democrats to come in and vote for Nikki
Haley basically sabotaging the
Republican primary process why does the
why does the part why does the state
party of Iowa allow that like why does
the Republican state party of Iowa allow
that it's absolutely no sense here's a
question how long you've been in Iowa a
we less than a week you've met some
people You' gotten out you went to
restaurants y yeah have you met a Nikki
Haley supporter no no never not that I
know of yeah yeah it's it's like meeting
a dodo bird or or a Joe Biden voter try
yeah like try and capture you know try
and capture one for science science what
are you I've never I've never I don't
know one I've never seen one we've met
Joe Biden voters we've never I've never
met a Joe Biden supporter okay yeah they
voted against Trump essentially yeah and
and even like the leftists who are like
I voted for Biden it's like yeah I don't
like the guy at all I just think Trump's
a fascist or blah blah blah but I saw I
when I saw this uh thing from Mark Cuban
where he's like crossover voters you're
saying why does I allow it it's really
simple man Democrats probably a long
time ago switched their party with the
intention of sabotaging the primary we
we talked about it even in 2020 this is
a strategy of having your people go to
open primaries to choose whoever you
think is going to lose or just to cause
chaos and damage well if it makes any of
the folks in attendance are watching
feel better Liz Cheney tried to do this
in Wyoming and she lost by 40 points she
tried to get all the Democrats in
Wyoming to register and vote for her um
I don't think it's smart that some
states do it but that just the fact of
the matter but it's not about any state
doing it even if you have a closed
primary or caucus process a Democrat one
year ago re switches party affiliation
to Republican waiting for the moment
they can come and do this there's
nothing there's no way to stop it it
just means that Democrats are there are
a large percentage of democrat voters
who are lying to sabotage the Republican
primary I would like to thank your
program and and and what you guys do for
sending your reporters to the Nikki
Haley events and she has totally closed
the doors to most conservative media she
won't allow cameras inside of her stump
speeches she's terrified that her
speeches will get out there and so your
videos of like talking to the attendees
and say yeah I'll vote they say I'll
vote for Biden before I vote for Trump
like those are the First videos that
were actually coming out of the Nikki
Haley events this entire campaign cycle
so you guys get a great job on that well
that's uh shout out to cnr.com elad
eliahu doing this ground reporting elad
does a great job he doesn't go in he's
not yelling to people he just ask him a
basic question who are you supporting
Nick if it's not niik who will you vote
for and they say Biden and their voters
say Ukraine's the number one issue uh
you know these people are are not going
to be Trump voters and that's okay we
don't need them but uh the V has been
interesting he's attracting a new
demographic I think to the party and I
think a lot of when he eventually drops
out I think most of his if not all of
his supporters will come and vote for
president Trump yep um but you know he's
a young energetic guy uh and he attracts
a similar type of person that President
Trump does uh but V team are has really
made an effort to go after the the young
vote like the 18 20 year olds and uh you
know the Andrew P crowd it's it's
brilliant uh going for the younger voter
I think V's whole play is for the future
I do think the save Trump v v thing was
was a huge misstep but I think right now
and I to because right now with the V
versus Trump thing there's people are
getting attacked online by like crazy
you've got these DieHard Trump
supporters saying they're all grifters
yeah okay look I'm gonna throw some
criticism at Ian miles Chong because he
posted that really deceptive image that
was like mainstream media esque where
it's a very tight shot from the third
row of a trump rally and then behind V
at his whole room when apparently
Trump's Trum Trump had like 2500 people
plus overflow a had 500 capacity like
let's not play those games we don't need
to do that but there are a lot of people
that I think are are going hard after
anybody who is talking to V or or
interviewing him claiming that this a
paid coordinated thing totally not true
possible I don't know maybe some people
are getting paid by V's campaign we
didn't get anything uh from V except I
will say full disclosure the building we
are in lur lmer tweeted that we are in
his campaign office technically correct
not literally correct his campaign
office is down the hall around the
corner I think that's fair to point out
we are in an unused portion of the
building we actually had to talk with
the owner about the use of the space and
and what it meant and I'm I'm just going
to tell everybody is we actually we were
like at odds with the vate campaign
because they're super noisy and we're
trying to do a show but I'm like I don't
want to disrupt someone else's campaign
yeah they've given us full access to
that office which is where I got my tea
as in VI campign they're being really
nice
being bought off by te that's right
that's right but I want to make sure
we're being transparent and clear with
that but I but I also want to point out
that when Laura Point uh mentioned about
being loyal to Trump I don't think she
articulated that very well I don't like
loyalty in politics what do you guys
think no no hold on I want to address
this this is the point why I'm bringing
it up there is an issue of being
honorable and loyal to Donald Trump and
I agree with it now let all the disas
people scream Maga cult BS whatever no
I'll tell you what it means it means I
didn't vote for Donald Trump in 2016 and
then I saw president who started no new
Wars I saw him set deadlines for ending
these Foreign Wars which the Democrats
told me were all bad during Obama but it
but made worse he brings in Abraham
Accords he negotiates with North Korea
all of these great foreign policy moves
some bad ones don't get me wrong but an
overall net positive and the whole time
they're destroying his life they're
targeting his children his net worth is
dropping now they're trying to take from
him his properties in New York City with
a with a with a fraudulent trial he's
being criminally prosecuted across the
board I'm sorry man when it comes to the
issue of loyalty I can ignore policy and
say I'm not going to abandon a guy and
vote for V after this guy jumped in the
trench and caused himself personal
damage to do good things for me and the
United States that's loyalty but that
being said between V and Trump I
understand V's point about they're going
to try and stop him agreed however
Donald Trump has experience in his first
term I believe that if if V were to win
right now he would not be as effective
as Trump in certain areas because he
will step on the landmines that they
laid out for Trump in the first term
that Trump now knows about so I I still
think there's a logical path forward for
why Donald Trump is the right person to
pick and I also think there's a question
of honor and loyalty to a guy who's
sacrificing a lot well so honor don't
turn away from who you believe in
because of fear I agree with that but I
believe that we should be loyal to the
process and it sounds like you're loyal
to Trump's process which I understand
but if what does that mean you're loyal
to his actions what he's done is like I
want more of that I I respect humans
that do that thing but no that's that's
not correct you're saying all the things
he did it's not about like I love the
guy no matter what he does I'll vote for
him I'm saying he I'm saying you could
can ignore the good things he's done
that's that's that's my point if we take
all of his policies and everything he
did for this country and just put a
blanket over it and say the only wish
issue we are addressing is this man ran
to be president ignited a base and they
have been stabbing him in the back
relentlessly that guy made sacrifices
for me I won't abandon him no I don't
like that but I I think I hear where
you're coming from though but and and I
think for the voters I don't think
voters necessarily have to be loyal to a
person right I think president Trump has
earned a lot of respect and a lot of
appreciation from the voters and that's
why they're going to vote for him
tonight and across the country but when
when Laura ler I think when she's
talking about the Loyalty I think she's
talking about people like aanda santis
who was a backbench congress member
until he got in his hands and knees and
cried in front of trump begging him for
his endorsement basically getting the
coronation to become governor of Florida
president Trump worked with him made
sure he got in he got rally after rally
after rally Des santis was running TV
ads you know basically saying you know
I'm president Trump's number one guy and
you know build the wall reading Trump
books to his kids and he embraced a
trump brand to become who he is today
and then he totally ditched Trump uh
when it became politically convenient
for him and then when you look at some
of these other influencers that Laura
lom's in the trenches fighting online
Simply Built their audiences like I look
at Tim different than I look at some of
these other folks look at Jenna Ellis
because Jenna Ellis built her audience
off of the back of trump supporters and
president Trump Tim built his audience
on his own doing his own thing and so
who he wants to support he can support
who he wants but when you're Jenna Ellis
or you're a John cardillo or you're a
bill Mitchell and you're content is only
I love Trump for five six years and just
in the reply section defending him and
all of a sudden you switch well like
that's where people
like Loy and their followers left them
and Dr Bill Mitchell lost 990,000
followers over the last you know year
because he became the biggest to Santa
shill John cildo similar situation and
so like but that like loyalty matters to
that to that extent but uh I don't think
the voters necessarily have to be loyal
but I think president Trump certainly
makes a great case I I'm loyal yeah John
c i it took me a second and then it
process I'm loyal to the US Constitution
and the process of the American function
and if someone better comes along than
the person I've been supporting for 20
years I'll vote for the new better
person and if that person that I've been
supporting goes crazy they should step
down and get out of way so the next guy
can come and that's how our systems buil
agreed and I don't I don't see that
playing a role right now yeah but I
think the other question too is if
somebody has been good for 20 years how
do you know that the person who's coming
up isn't just good in rhetoric and
they're actually going to be decent when
they take office because that's one of
the values that's one of the benefits of
having a political leader who has some
experience is you're able to say okay I
know what their track record is whereas
this other guy could have great rhetoric
but I don't know what he's going to do I
loyalty is in like military and monarchy
I don't think it has a place in
republics we got some numers coming so
uh less than 1% of the votes have come
in already it is 7:30 Donald Trump is at
67.5% with 243 votes Des sand is in
second Nikki Haley is in third V Rami in
fourth is that good for Trump so far
this is good for Trump I'm not good at
math who's the guy that voted for Chris
Christie there's one vote for Chris
Christie Ryan Binkley got a vote his
wife voted for Ryan Binkley house wife
voted for I'm I'm real sorry ASA
Hutchinson still running you said he's
still running and he got zero and chrisy
got one
I'm Sor so look if I if I were caucusing
tonight and I'm from Iowa and I've
caucused before as an Iowan I no longer
live in Iowa I live in
Florida I would not be caucusing for
Ronda sand I'd be caucusing for Donald
Trump I fully expect to vote for Donald
Trump in 2024 in a general election my
issue with the whole my issue with the
whole what Alex is talking about but
then also this whole like loyalty
argument is I think at the root of it is
we injected money into the influencer
world and we able to flip influencers in
a very cringy way talk a little bit
about cringe political campaigns here
and uh I'm not going to name anyone but
it's fully available for everyone to see
online who's getting paid it's also
fully available in FEC reports you can
go check who's on the payroll of which
campaigns right bigname influencers you
can go find them all the reports are
public and I don't like that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net